la talk radio
how did you raise money for the the film
the sacred the last film odyssey it
would just between me and my producer we
put which basically just for fun a
little bit of money and i think she she
here to be i was shooting another film
called the tenant it's a feature film
for another person to another director
very nice cell and then I was coming out
of that and a producer friend of mine
just I had heard that my little film
delivery had done really well video it
games like a cold spell Muslim County
and she's like why don't we just make a
film and I'm like [ __ ] it's not that
easy you know do you have any money and
it's like yes it will no she said no I
was like okay can you get some money I
think she found out about ten thousand
dollars from a grandmother yeah so is
your grandmother's give her ten grand
and as I and I was like of course I was
I wasn't planning on going back and just
doing you know going to get this it's a
lot of work just a lot of work when
there's no money there's just so much
work yeah do this behind kissing in so
much so there's so much stuff you need
to do is just it's a given birth